[Music]
all of our dogs on the table yes so
we've got two Italian Greyhounds peach
and Kermit and one small Chihuahua named
mr. models inappropriately we're gonna
talk about them today yeah we decipher
pump that they're allowed in the park is
there so far being okay they're usually
never allowed because this is so loud
and bad yeah and we are also this is a
double-double new thing for this podcast
we're periscope Ferris company right
here we're all linked to periscope below
is Jenna Julian Potter on periscope but
we decided that it would probably be the
easiest solution because we can do it
from the iPad instead of bringing the
whole computer in here yeah so we're
gonna see we're test driving it right
now but I used to live Ustream we did
and yeah there was like 15 people we
would have on the used to be so they
could watch the podcast live and then
once we got the new setup it was just
kind of too difficult because I got my
computer right here recording audio and
having a second computer was just a
little bit of a headache actually it was
in the opiate that man [ __ ] oh hello
Martha but we wanted to talk about kind
of will you talk about our dogs we wanna
talk about funny stories because these
dogs are so absolute goons they're just
so weird all the time
and it's all of their birthday's coming
up soon in June they all have birthday
month
ya know whenever we're around and like
they are not left to their own devices
they they're pretty good you know like
when normally when we come in here to
podcast we come out and some [ __ ] habit
because they're just like rebelling like
peach will tear the couch pillows apart
anyway she and naughty these are our
dogs
we sit for the mic enough thermal
Wranglers over here she's gonna use her
hand it just knocked over your mic in a
sec hi periscope I can't even see me but
so we have a bunch of stories Jenna's
got more than I do because she's got
more dogs than I do but we figured let's
just get into her yeah yeah I got the
multi right here oh yeah
call me mr. clutch in a manual car okay
so I decided that I was gonna talk about
marble first since he's the oldest
marbles is gonna be 7 on June 5th
peach is gonna be 1 on June 15th and
Kermit's gonna be 5 on June 20th
birthday month coming up
ok so my first story is the first time
that marble ever barked ok so I used to
live in this like like a three-story
house in Cambridge and why are you just
playing here because you're talking
about when I tell us sorry I'll put it
on me
and so he hadn't made a noise I got him
when he was you know 6 weeks old or
something like that little like he was a
pound he was the size of just like a
baby bird and he was running around this
like parking lot of a backyard that we
shared with the two upper units and in
Boston a lot of times like in the
basement there's like these small little
windows that are right against the
ground ok and there you know rectangular
yeah yeah so like the dirt basement like
the laundry oh yes I know what you're
talking about like when you walk into
the side of the house you see a moment
yeah yeah yeah and marble was you know
super super little and tiny and he
walked up to one of those windows saw
his own reflection and went it was the
first time I ever I love that I you were
obviously there I think for the first
time peach bark Torme no no it was so
cute it's first part like such a weird
their voice is
because they all have different like
sounding barks yeah oh yeah that's
really cool it was really cute all right
those marbles all right you want to
because you all right go ahead well the
next one we both had switch I bought
that in a minute okay um so marble like
he's he got I fixed him when he was like
two so he said marvel
he's a little like humps things like he
used to hump things a lot before I got
him fixed yeah he's pretty awful and the
reasoning behind me not fixing him till
two was like I was it was complicated I
mean but it basically boiled down to you
can't do anything with your dog if
they're not fixed yeah like you can't
take them to parks legally and I was
like okay buddy sorry I'm really sorry
yeah so he's still like humps a lot of
things whereas these two don't hump
anything because they got fixed
relatively young yeah Kermit super
submissive in peach is just a little
baby go baby go
so marbles like instead of just humping
like anything and everything he chooses
one stuffed animal and he humps it until
the stuffed animal is like gone or dead
yeah and so he's gone through a couple
in his life he had a lion and then I got
him the exact same lion when Kermit
wrecked it and then for a little while
was a bear but now he's currently on a
bear the bear yeah but like at night
when we go upstairs he'll just like
stand at the edge of the bed like look
for it he'll like start wagging his tail
and freaking out because he wants you to
find his bear yeah so that he can hump
it and if like one of the other dogs
touches it he like flips out but it's
just really adorable to me that's
something with the size of like a brain
the size of a walnut can be so
emotionally attached to one and and
there it's funny because I can sometimes
we'll be in a hotel somewhere and we'll
have the dogs and we'll have forgotten
the bear but we'll have another stuffed
animal and he'll understand that that's
like his temporary he'll have to make do
and you can see he's like he's like
reluctant but he'll do it with the bear
he's like all about it it's like his
go-to he's completely adore it's really
cute yeah but then like dirt
because I've seen other dogs be attached
to one stuffed animal yeah and they'll
carry it with them and like bring it
with them they'll play with it all day
marbles literally like will go to bed he
like will hump his bear for like three
minutes maybe and then go to sleep but
he's like so he like lives for that
three minutes really no thank you
it's pretty adorable okay so mine is
pretty relevant because you know tweeted
about it today and it happens like today
and last night so we had cheat meal last
night and we got some Taco Bell and
Jenna got a Crunchwrap supreme which is
like a little flat little kind of whole
quesadilla sort of sealed meat thing I
don't know what she gave me day yeah
so first what happened was every time we
leave the living room and there's any
sort of food there it's just a matter of
time before Pete's just like you know
gets the balls to get up and just take
it like she knows she's not supposed to
but she's got her on video it's trying
to get out right so it's on my vlog
today when you're watching this it'll be
on my vlog that's her know it might be
you know it's the next vlog it's coming
out tomorrow but anyway I set up my
camera and I was like [ __ ] I'm
gonna catch you because I know you're
gonna do it anyway so I put up the
camera and she sure enough goes and like
takes the Crunchwrap and like tries to
drag it off and I like yellow I'm like
Paige I got you and she's like oh my god
oh my god but anyway that was last night
today yeah I had only eaten like a
quarter that she took a bite of it me
know the whole thing was just sitting
there I was sitting in the living room
and we forgot to like throw it out last
night so we come downstairs today and
we're downstairs for maybe like five
minutes I'm drinking coffee Jenna's like
checking her phone like it's just waking
up time and I go in the living room and
I see that there's no Crunchwrap but
there's a wrapper I go outside I go
outside and I say Jenna did you show off
the clothes rep last night and she said
no and I said okay well I can't find it
and I think the dogs just took it so
it's somewhere in the house right now so
I spent like 15 minutes
no all right calm down I spent like 15
minutes like searching the living room
lifting [ __ ] up finding you know a whole
bunch of [ __ ] but not the Crunchwrap so
it's just in the house now it's
literally we haven't found it so in like
three weeks we're going to find an old
as Crunchwrap were they aided the whole
thing maybe the whole thing well her and
Kermit work together like the Raptors in
Jurassic Park so that is exactly what
they do they literally work together
it's insane it's crazy I texted Jordan
spoderman yeah Jordan please I was gonna
hold a candlelight vigil for them the
secret you tweeted that's my first story
guys you need to calm down Julia that's
that's her fault peach you're being
disruptive okay you're gonna be in my
shirt in a second stay no licking be
guests your guests okay
yeah and my next one was about marble
okay I'm pretty sure that I've told the
story before but I had made a video a
long time ago about this kid that I was
roommates with that I hated like I hated
this guy so many levels for so many
things
yeah but one of the things that also
hated was he how to rabbit being Jasmine
was this little black rabbit yeah I
guess he bought it for his niece and
then he kept it and it was just really
weird
and this guy was very bizarre and he
just [ __ ] hated him and he would
leave this rabbit on the back deck in
Boston like through all weather
conditions yeah and like sometimes he
would throw a tarp over it and because I
hated this guy so much he would heat
like he would tell me oh you know
whenever you're at home like if you want
to just like take Jasmine out and play
with her and stuff I'm sure she'd
appreciate it and I'm like I hate you
but I love me some bunnies and so
because they're sweet and adorable and
so on the back deck I would let Jasmine
out and she play with marbles and it was
the cutest thing because marbles is such
a little guy and she was like a little
rabbit no it was before I had Kermit
yeah and they would just like play
together and it was completely adorable
and like he would like let this rabbit
go days without giving her fresh water
and food and like I would notice it and
like you can only do so much
I mean it's not your rabbit like I can't
expect on it every day
I'm sure [ __ ] hate the kid and one
day I went out there and it was dead and
the only reason I know is because
marbles walked up to the cage and you
know usually he would just walk up to
her occasion likes wag his tail and
start getting all excited that I was
gonna
out yeah and he just looked at her cage
and then looked at me and went that's so
sad and it was the saddest thing in the
whole world but for a while marbles best
friend was a rabbit named Jasmine it's
really cute but sad sad ending
marble-like he was very if anybody has a
rabbit
just know that marbles will get along
swimmingly I'd rather just come over for
a playdate marbles my friend did you sit
being two while your brother
trap him okay so this isn't really a
single story because speech says it all
the time but he's just a little Goyal
she loves to be boiled and does going
out things like she girl things like she
takes she'll take Jenna's underwear out
of Jenna's your little wedge of the drew
up and take the underwear but we didn't
have any underwear we know I would
always say how we saw Jenna just shut
your door your drawer and you would have
a problem and she would be like I know I
know and I'm telling you I was like
Julian I shut it every day yeah I
believe her I'm like Jenna just actually
shut it like shut it and then you know
one day she caught peach any act of
pulling the door from the drawer from
completely shut to open like she opens
the drawer her underwear drawer
Raptors like a raptor anyway so peach
will take her underwear all the time
anyway we caught her one time in the bed
upstairs in our bedroom with a bra like
she was basically wearing the bra like
it was over her and then around her and
she had underwear in her mouth just like
the biggest little girl
I've caught her so many times like she
doesn't even just chew it she ends up
like wearing it on her body it's like a
little girl baby that you have who just
wants to be like a big girl so bad and I
caught her ziploc bag full of like my
like lip glosses and stuff that she'd
taken out of my backpack because she
just like she loves my makeup upstairs
she chews it all up it's the most
adorable thing honestly you can even be
mad but it's not like she's over here
chewing Julian's stuff no she's
definitely my girl
yeah a little that's well that's one of
my page stories no baby go baby go and
she really she's so adorable because she
looks like she's got like eyeliner on
and mascara like her eyes are dark
around the edges and it's really cute in
my next story is about them sermons so I
had only had Sarah mouth for like I want
to say like four months yeah and he was
also you know six or eight weeks old and
it got him so he wasn't old at all like
a few months old yeah and it was
Valentine's Day and you know like when
you have a new dog and you're sort of
letting them feel out things and you
think you have a good grasp on what
they're capable of doing you're getting
on or whatever yeah you're testing I
completely had no idea and underestimate
like I had never seen him do it under I
underestimated his ability to get on to
things yeah because you think you have
this dog you know maybe it'll you know
jump up on your bed or something like
that well he had recently just figured
out how to jump up onto these tall
barstools and got onto the counter in
the kitchen and there was a like a
heart-shaped box of little Reese's
peanut butter cups like the little mini
ones and I came home to my like four or
five month old puppy or whatever six
months old puppy and all the rappers
were just strewn everywhere and I'm like
oh my god
like he just ate all this chocolate like
he's gonna die like I was like horrified
like I literally think I went to go get
a sandwich or something like it was that
fast and I I was like panicking
panicking and I'm just looking at Kermit
and he was just sort of like looking
around like oh oh
oops so I panicked and I like called the
vet and it was actually one of the most
helpful things ever because I was under
the impression that my dog had just ate
like he had eaten a ton of chocolate but
she was like no they're actually like
the peanut butter cups most of it's
peanut butter and it's also wrapped in
milk chocolate which helps so it's
actually you know X amount of cocoa
so she care per cup she was like tell me
how many are in the box I'm like well I
don't know like 25 or something but it
looks like he ate like 15 I don't know
and so she she calculated how much
actual chocolate that he ingested per
his body weight yeah
and she was like he's gonna be fine like
he's just gonna be really hyper and
probably have some diarrhea yeah and so
I was just like in tears like so happy
and excited that's insane I can't even
believe that's how it went down like she
just right there for you blink of an eye
all of a sudden you're like oh my god
do I need to take my dog to get his like
stomach pumped right now well that's I
mean Herman and now forever now Kermit
loves chocolate like he look I know and
that's what the vet told me she was like
well now you just be aware that since
he's had chocolate and tastes of
chocolate they're like people they
develop a taste for the chocolate so
he'll try and get into chocolate again
like a little [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah he
does however you're eating chocolate Oh
naughty so naughty but that was
terrifying and he did that when he was a
little baby
mm-hmm Kermit's a naughty he also but he
also I know I made vlogs years ago on my
vlog Channel I had a doggie door in
Boston and Kermit
caught 13 rats by the time yeah he's a
killer 4 or 5 months old is that Jasmine
the rabbit after this is what a shipped
bag that kid was after the rabbit had
died in its cage he just took the rabbit
cage and like dropped it down onto the
like pavement like there's a chain-link
fence then there's a strip of pavement
around it and then there was our deck
which was small but he had just dropped
the empty like plastic container onto
the ground so it would like rain and
like just it was filled with like this
green
disgusting like rainwater and slick snow
they dispose of the body
I I think so God but it was just this
classic container full of water and so I
thought it was like kind of cute when
Kermit had brought me a couple of rats
cuz I'm like that's really sweet you
know I get it you're trying to give me a
present but then you know there's only
so much space outside and go outside
bring in a rat and I'm like where in the
[ __ ] is he getting all these rats from
it's not like it's a giant space to play
in and it's most of it's a deck like
where are you getting this restaurant so
I finally I was like I'm gonna sit
outside and I'm gonna watch him all
[ __ ] day until I figure out where
these rats are coming from so that they
can stop you didn't mean and what was
happening was the rats were coming from
wherever but because there was this
thing of standing water they would just
come and perch on the edge of this empty
rabbit cage of yours and drink out of it
and Kermit like an alligator like in a
safari would just [ __ ] kill them like
as they were drinking the water so I was
like [ __ ] right so I dumped all the
water out and then he stopped bringing
me rats because you stopped came in red
blooded killer isn't he I think Pete's
bringing sticks from outside is like
annoying that would I know it was cute
for a little while until it was like
where all these rats coming from and
this is disgusting yeah like dead rats
everywhere holy [ __ ] well he would drop
them like on my bed like at the end of
the bed and like on the bathroom like
mat well so that he was doing double
dick he's a guy I'm gonna drop the very
first time he dropped it on the foot of
my bed and in my bathroom or two
bathroom and just to make sure that I
saw them both that's rough he's a sweet
boy
but true so you know if you ever have
any rat problems peaches - nice just
feel like struggling to like kill that
fly the other day well you weren't there
but he has almost killed that possum
here and at the previous house multiple
times that possums asking for it though
I mean come on possum I thought he was
gonna kill that possum I had I had to
let the costume get away I remember that
you like Sada's ass oh yeah cuz I don't
know Danielle's our backyard either
those things are nasty and rabies and
girl [ __ ]
alright so my next story I was running
peach we went for a run and I would I
used to work and where I would have to
be in the studio for like six hours at a
time to board up and I would like to
take peach when she was a real real
young puppy but I had to like run her or
else she would be off the wall and I
couldn't like do my job
so I was running her this this one
morning and she was on the leash and we
were running relatively good speed like
I don't even know seven to ten miles an
hour and some streets around our
neighborhood don't have sidewalks so
that you're like running on the grass
kind of side part of someone's lawn you
know instead of the street which will
have like street signs and things on it
that a sidewalk would have so we're
running we're running and you know we're
on this little grass patch and up in
front of us about ten yards is a parking
sign and we're running and we're like
you know we're off to the sack so we're
nowhere near the parking sign and right
as we about like are approaching the
sign she out of nowhere just bolts to
like the street like she's on my leash
she's not getting into the street but
she bolts it that way towards the curb
and like the sign and I have like zero
time to react so I stopped as fast as I
can but it was too late because she
believed she clotheslined herself so the
leash hit the pole and she went like
this way and she just got choked and
fell on her back and I was like and
someone saw it happen so I like drop
down I like I fell I turned around I was
like are you okay I thought she like
broke her neck or punctured or whatever
and she was fine she's totally fine and
I think a hundred percent it was uh
attributed to the factory was wearing a
martingale collar like this really thick
padded collar where when you tug on it
it only tightens so much so I think that
helped a lot but she totally just like
clotheslined herself to the point where
she just like it was pretty freaky but
she's just a little like a sight house
so I saw something and just
my in my list of stories to that the
first time that we took her for a walk
she literally just stood there and she
didn't know what to do she had no like
we're gonna walk now yeah she was so
stressed out my dogs are like [ __ ]
let's go for like a good I I would say
for like a good for like a good month
maybe two months I would have to carry
treats on the walk and just made her to
walk ya know here's how it went like I
would have to bait her to walk to the
first three corner with treats and by
the time we got to that corner she was I
got it and then we just walked the whole
walk with it without treats but it was
just getting out of the house down to
the first corner she didn't understand
where we go where we going why are we
are walking thought she was expected
that's weird too because both of mine
like you they're just so happy to go on
a walk I know and she was yeah and like
she was happy to walk but she didn't
know how to play cuz she wanted to get
out okay I had a three stories about
Kermit chasing or getting chased or
being chased or whatever so the first
one was at my old place in Cambridge and
he was still a baby there it was like a
big there's a baseball field and a big
field that's in sort of the center of
our neighborhood and um you know in like
a big place like that especially in a
big city like there in Boston they
weren't really a ton of dog parks yeah
and like a lot of people and the my kid
maybe seven or eight in the morning and
then like five or six at night like
before and after work like people would
congregate it sort of in the middle of
this giant field with their dogs so that
was sort of like our neighborhoods dog
park but it wasn't completely fenced in
their fences all around but they have
those gaps so that you can walk in and
out yeah it's not like it closes got it
and so you know people would just go
they're sort of on their honor and watch
their dogs and you know no one had a
problem with that
yeah and so I would bring Kermit there
you know in the morning and at night and
stuff and be part of the little dog
group and lalala and I I have so many
mixed feelings about people bringing
their young young children to areas
where there's a lot of dogs and
sort of gives me a little bit of anxiety
because not all of them know how to act
around dogs and people we've seen that
I've seen that and people sort of you
know are like oh she loves dogs I'm like
yeah okay that's fine whatever
so Kermit like you know they tell you
especially with Italian Greyhounds and
other greyhounds and whippets since
their sight hounds that you should never
ever let them off leash and you know I
I've done what I can with Kermit and I
think you're doing the same thing with
Pete whereas like if you build a really
really strong bond with them there are
exceptions to that rule you know what I
mean and I was building like really
great trust with Kermit and he was doing
really well and he's also like too
skittish to ever really take off but he
was you know young and still learning
and this [ __ ] kid like this little
girl maybe she was like five years old
she starts chasing Kermit and the kids
do this a lot with them because they're
so fast and they're funny-looking and
all that
she started chasing Kermit and I'm
telling her I'm like honey like don't
chase him you're scaring him like he
doesn't like that and she just like
[ __ ] is racing like screaming and
like trying to grab him and Kermit was
so scared of this little girl like my
house was literally just across the
street of one of those gaps in the fence
so he took off out of this field and ran
all the way to the front steps of my
house which you can still see and it
wasn't that far away but I was
terrifying oh it was so terrifying that
he had ran into the street and it's like
you know the only time he's ever done
anything like that he was a little baby
and I just wanted to [ __ ] find that
little kid's mother and be like what the
[ __ ] is your problem like you cannot
chase dogs imagine if he was sort of
like an [ __ ] at that point like if
you turned around and bit her their
parent would have sued me like I got
something
yeah and it just it is what it is that's
whatever for another day that was one of
the scariest things yeah with karma
being chased and another time karma
being chased he's just like he loves
being chased but dogs when they get it
and I think of Winston my brothers when
he sees Kermit like they want to chase
him yeah wait he's terrified it doesn't
want to chase anymore yeah it's like not
a game anyway yeah I was at a big an
actual dog park a big giant dog park
with Kermit and there's no separation
for small dogs and big dogs so you kind
of just got to go and figure it out and
he was again little like under a year
yeah and this the probably the biggest
German Shepherd I've ever seen in my
life started chasing him and so Kermit
is you know we have a good bond going
and so instead of running away like he
did before so he had like learned a
little bit from that little girl
experience that I don't really want to
run away he starts circling me like
literally orbiting me and this driven
Shepherd is just chasing him around me
to the point where this German Shepherd
was like kicking up giant like hunks of
grass it was running so fast in a circle
and like I'm just sort of standing there
like I don't really know what to do dude
I knew it Karma's just running running
running it around me like you know the
circumference is like this baby yeah and
then all of a sudden I hear Kermit start
going my poor little Kermit didn't know
which was worse like to keep running or
to like stop like the German Shepherd
was just playing yeah he's just like cry
running but Kermit had never been really
chased by a big dog yeah that much yeah
he did he like didn't know what to do so
it was like two whole minutes of I had
to like intervene yeah yeah that's too
bad you know it's unfortunate when dog
owners don't act right and the last
story about him chasing ya was when I
was in fishtail Montana I was driving
across the country he saw a deer we were
in a big giant open field again and he
saw a deer yeah and so he just chased
after it yeah and he got right up to the
deers face it was really close the dirty
clothes
and he got right up to the deers face
and they just stare at each other for
like way too long yeah yeah just don't
break eye contact and then all of a
sudden chemicals who's like buddy you
what did you think was gonna happen when
you got to the deer he didn't think it
through
he is a deer he's a baby she was a very
pretty deer though wasn't June it wasn't
one of those big crazy ones she was
literally just like hey I got two more
stories yeah all right so here's some of
these stories just a funny kind of
coincidence circumstance thing so I got
peach on August 17th or 16th I can't
remember it was a Saturday and I got
peach we went to the airport I've logged
it and anyway we we got her and it was
just like welcome home peach it was the
first day I had her she was I I believe
eight weeks old because that's like the
soonest I could get her two months old
and and and it was like my first date
with her we were like getting her kind
of warmed up to the house she's like
she's really excited then she falls
asleep and then she's really excited
then fall asleep so it's like a first
day with a puppy like a puppy yeah and
we go to sleep and the next day Jenna
had a shoot with pitbull she was on the
fire ball music video and we were you
know obviously I was invited to go with
her or whatever and Jenna was like you
know we just got this new puppy and the
people's people and stuff they're just
like yeah bring her like maybe she could
be in the video he's [ __ ] me or
whatever so I'm like well I'm not gonna
leave her at home for sure duh but I'm I
don't really want to not go to this
shoot with you I want to be there so I
took Peach and I had her in my arms the
entire time she was this big she was
like like like three-quarters the size
of marbles right now she's so small and
she's still like learning everything
about everything she knows nothing Jon
Snow but anyway so I had her in my arms
she she had her little hoodie and I
think she had like this blank
and I just carried her around the
pitbull shoot with me the entire night
she was there she was there her second
day yeah it was really really funny and
bright there with us and he was it was
just like a really cute thing I think I
still have some pictures from her but
she didn't get to meet people no pitbull
was too busy but she met everyone like
all the crew and everyone like they need
to realize I had a puppy and they were
like oh my god that's a head she was
that small she's her second she did she
and uh before we actually got to set
Jenna was that her at a trailer getting
makeup done I like went out to this
grass field and like try to get her to
pee and it took me like 10 minutes but
she finally like went to the bathroom
which was like that much I carried her
so what about marbles flipping out
okay um where times the what was it
Kermit
can I tell the Marvel story real
question okay so marbles like he's
that's marbles he's very small and our
weaver he doesn't really know how to get
up on things he's very small he can jump
decently high first size but he's no
Kerman or peach like think he can't jump
high or jump down from high places and
we have stairs to the bed for him
because he can't get up on the bed
because our beds decently high and uh
he gets in these weird moods where he's
like really daring and he just kind of
does whatever mom like he it's almost
like he's on one like he's he's he's
feeling really confident but to the
point of like it's freaking me out a
little bit and one day Jenna and I both
saw this happen never seen anything was
the most it was like it was like a
spectacle because it didn't make sense
visually like the size and the
proportions but he runs to the side he's
on the head of our bed where the pillows
are he runs really [ __ ] high he runs
it's like us jumping off a two-story
building but he runs Sprint's to the
edge of the bed I think we were like do
you guys want to go somewhere and he
jumps off the bed and soars like across
the whole room and slides onto the wood
floor oh I'm sorry I didn't mean this
kind of but he flies off the bed and he
just like stumbles
to the ground and we just like him he
was fine yeah break his legs no he
looked like he totally wanted to do it
too like that it was completely out of
nowhere because he he like twisted in
the air like you and then he landed on
the ground yeah just took off man it was
the weirdest thing I've ever seen like
that's what I wanted to say it was
insane oh my god it was one of the
weirdest things ever but it was so like
I can't like we had to have both seen it
because one of us describing it so the
other would have been like not doing it
justice yeah you wouldn't believe you
wouldn't understand
my last year were about Kermit [ __ ]
okay what's here oh my god yes Kermit is
kind of a nervous pooper yeah and he
will hold his poop until like the middle
of the night when no one's watching and
then go poo try and poop in the bathroom
yeah he's he's gotten better
he's gotten a lot better for a while it
was bad but he like he gets nervous than
he poops yeah so when he was little
little I really wanted him to have like
a crate and be happy with a crate like a
safe place you don't I mean like a
covered den basically yeah and I wasn't
going to use it for anything other than
just like here's your here's your home
you don't mean there and so I put Carmen
in the crate and you know you're
supposed to do it in small intervals of
time while you're still in the room and
help them like leave the door open or
anything like that
so I was sort of trying to get him to do
it he wouldn't even like put his body
anywhere near it yeah and he was
freaking out so I literally was just
like I closed the door and I'm like it's
okay Kermit it's all right and he [ __ ]
everywhere in the crate everywhere and
then he turned around in it and he got
his hands all over it and he smeared it
all over the crate like it was it was
like watching someone's like freak the
[ __ ] out and it happened so fast and
then that was the last time I haven't
closed the crater Carmen gets nervous he
moves at this like really like panicked
speed and he does things like dude calm
down but there's no calming him down
it's like he's in his weird and nervous
it's ridiculous yeah
so um although recently within the last
two years or so like my brother left a
big soft crate for his dogs at my house
yeah like it kind of pops up like a -
yeah
criminals sitting out all the time he
only sits in it because it's on his it's
on his but he likes crates
yeah he just felt like trapped okay next
time this was even worse
so in this house that we currently live
in
you know whenever I'm renting a place
I'm like I just need to find a place
that has the least amount of carpet
possible yeah because it's not that the
dogs want to go on the carpet all the
time or have accidents all the time but
when it does it's just such a [ __ ]
headache that I don't want to deal with
yeah I mean yeah and so Kermit the only
place in this house that has carpets are
in the closets yeah so there's his and
hers closets their little closets a
little tiny room was a little like
carpet in it and so we're really good
about keeping the door closed so that
they don't get in the only spot of
carpet we're really good about it
and so Kermit was following me around
the bedroom I was like getting dressed
and you know oftentimes they'll try and
follow me into the closet and get in
there because that's the place they'd
never been is very exciting and you know
I sort of just closed the door behind me
because I was getting dressed and I'm
like I'm gonna close the door so the
dogs will get in there and all of a
sudden I realized that Kermit's aunt
around and I'm like Kermit where's
Kermit where's Kermit and maybe I made
it in half maybe 45 seconds yeah yeah
and I opened my closet door like oh my
god maybe Kermit's my closet he had got
so panicked that I had closed the door
behind him he diarrhea shat all over the
only square of carpet in the entire
house like it was wet it was there was
everywhere it was everywhere like I
don't even know how he did it in that
short of time I got it's not positive
was it was it like an oh he covered us
five square feet of poo my god full but
no like if you were to square off the
closet each square
I would say five different squares had
some little remnants of poo on it like
he spread it everywhere it was
ridiculous
and as soon as I open the door it's that
sense just wafted everywhere and I'm
like how was that even in your body yeah
that one was a fun one to clean up it
was ridiculous he's so fun
yeah Kermit is by far the weirdest dog
ya know anytime you think they're being
weird
Kermit always out weirds them anyway I
have one last story it's not gross so
I'll end it on a non gross poopy note so
I would say like a couple days like
maybe five days oh you know like maybe a
week in the having peach at home like
very very young still floppy is how
still very very small and all energetic
like from the moment she came home she
just wanted to play with her big brother
Kermit like she just want to run with
him but he would trample on her like he
would just outrun her and she wouldn't
get it like she would just keep playing
and Brett came over one day and he was
like hanging out with Jenna like over by
the the we had a pool at our old place
and there was like a barbecue with it
like a little area on the steps where he
would sit and they were sitting over
there and I was kind of like encouraging
the dogs I would love to like run around
with them and like you know like taunt
them and make them run with me you know
I'm the baddest a right yeah so they're
running in circles Kermit and peach and
peaches way slower and way flop here but
Kermit's like nimble and fast and out of
Noah and I'm standing like right by the
pool I'm just I just so happy for like
two days yeah it was very young it was
under a week anyway
I just happened to be standing right
next to the pool like I don't know why I
was there I could have been on the other
end of the line but I was there at that
moment and I looked down and as I'm like
looking down Kermit is running like he's
edging the pool peach is taking the
inside lane and Kermit cuts her off and
hurt the back of Kermit's body just
knocks peach into the pool like and she
just goes she gets knocked in the pool
and I like I hear it and I see it and I
look into the pool and I just see this
puppy like drifting down to the moon
looking up at me like
her back like it's the Titanic she's
just like this and I like I dive in like
the top of my body cause it's a shallow
end I grab her I bring her up and I'm
like are you she's totally fine she just
like had no idea what had happened but
it was the most like such a poppy moment
like she just wanted to play with the
big dogs and got knocked in the pool it
was all so ridiculous too because like
Kermit would tear around that pool and I
was always like one day that little
moment cuz he's never been around a pool
he's gone so close to where you lake
fell when we moved in there I'm like
he's gonna fall in the pool that's got
to learn it totally has skidded out and
his back legs has gone yeah before but
he's never actually full ball yeah is he
right because he kind of really close
and he that he's never knocked marble
into the bladder but like peachy was so
little so shouldn't really even
understand that it was water you know I
think she just thought it was like a
little bit of a ledge yeah we're like
that [ __ ] is gonna fall in the pool and
she's got nothing so fast so fast under
a week of having her at home but I was I
was so happy that I'm standing right
because I wouldn't let her play outside
unless I was there for a while
especially the pool but it was just so
ridiculous and you guys saw in the pool
just like diving oh my god oh my god
anyway I loved the fact that we brought
them in here and they're just not
sleeping right here like this you why
can't we use every podcast
well they've actually impressed me so
maybe we will show periscope what they
look like yeah we still like Rosa I
think it's I think Paris
anyway thank you guys for watching this
podcast his dog podcast it was really
fun we will be back next week with
another podcast like I said Jenna
Julianne Cod on periscope if you care
[Music]